there is no one in India more powerful
than this man four years after leading
his party to a spectacular general
election win Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi remains a favorite to win
again in 2019 Modi travels the globe
promoting a new modern India they're
hugging world leaders along the way he
tweets regularly to his forty million
followers and even connects with
supporters through an app named after
him Prime Minister Modi and I are world
leaders in social media still Modi's
record is mixed there are questions
about whether the ground reality has
changed much under his leadership and
some of his biggest economic reforms
have caused confusion and disrupted the
economy this is the story of how
Narendra Modi is trying to rebrand India
as a modern economy and how the reality
does not always match the rhetoric since
taking office in 2014
Modi has become India's salesman in
chief he's largely singing the same tune
Yamano covers indian politics for
Bloomberg News in New Delhi come and
invest in India come start a business
here trade with us by Indian good no do
yoga he openly courts countries like
Japan Israel and Saudi Arabia and he's
gotten closer to the u.s. even
addressing a joint session of Congress
in 2016 to all of these countries his
message is the same India you know the
fastest growing large economy with the
most open investment by beach it's not
just a dusty place where you know people
hang off the sides of trains it's a new
modern economy
it's the skyscrapers in Bombay it's the
startups in Bangalore Modi came into
power with the reputation of being a
pro-business reformer for 13 years he
was the chief minister of the western
state of Gujarat where he presided over
more than a decade of rapid economic
growth his policies became known as the
Gujarat model and they were the promise
of what he might do for India
but his economic policies have gotten a
mixed reviews on the plus side he's open
millions of bank accounts for the poor
attractive more foreign direct
investment and India's eclipses China is
the world's fastest growing major
economy he's also seen a number of
setbacks in November 2016 Modi surprised
the nation by banning 86 percent of
India's cash overnight agent Lee news
will no longer be legal tender midnight
it was as if the u.s. found the $20 and
$100 bills overnight the idea was to
tackle so-called black money a local
term for cash stashed away to avoid
taxes a lot of poor people just thought
you know he was hitting the rich and
then you had his critics who said like
oh my god what are you what are you
doing you've just eliminated the vast
majority of cash in a country that
basically only operates on cash the day
after people lined up outside banks to
deposit their money and small businesses
didn't know how to pay their workers it
cost India's expansion to slow to a
three-year low then in June 2017 Modi
introduced a national sales tax called
the Goods and Services Tax or GST the
goal of the GST was to unify India's
complicated tax structure and make it
easier to do business but in some cases
the tax rates were really confusing say
one nut like a cashew would attract a
different tax than an almond or a peanut
so if you had a bag of mixed nuts what
was the tax rate nobody knew how to do
business people stopped buying things
and the economy basically seized up
while the cash banning GST have not been
economically beneficial in the short
term they still help build Modi's
reputation as an authoritative leader
there's no single reason for Modi's
enduring popularity on the political
side the Hindu nationalist agenda of his
Bharati a janitor Party or BJP has made
him electorally successful but it also
makes him controversial there are parts
of the population that will never
forgive Modi for his handling of the
2002 Gujarat riots which killed as many
as 2000 people mostly Muslims a lot of
human rights organizations accused the
government at the time which was run by
Modi it actually led to Modi being
denied a US visa but he was eventually
cleared of any wrongdoing more recently
he's come under fire for failing to
quickly condemn attacks by Hindu
nationalists on Muslims members of his
own party have even supported people
accused of raping and killing a young
Muslim girl
so while India has moved up 30 places in
the world banks Ease of Doing Business
rankings since Modi became prime
minister many of the problems that India
is known for lack of infrastructure
poverty malnutrition bad education
system bad health system haven't changed
much what has changed to some extent is
the momentum people see around India
Modi is trying to create an India that
people can believe in that people can be
hopeful about Modi remains India's most
popular leader many Indians are likely
to re-elect him in 2019 with the hope
that changes will come and it just takes
time
you
[Music]
you